florida republicans did not pick a fight
with disney but they sure seem to be
finishing a fight with disney you know
about the florida parental rights and
education bill this says that you can't
preach transgenderism to five-year-olds
seems pretty uncontroversial to me
but disney employees and eventually
disney leadership took issue with this
law they believe that your six-year-olds
and seven-year-olds and kindergartners
and preschoolers and everybody else
should be taught transgenderism and all
sorts of sexual ideologies and so they
are vowing to fight florida republicans
and fight these sorts of bills around
the country as well
so
florida republicans have proposed to
remove
these special
tax exemptions that disney has really
elevating this fight and saying no what
corporations are not going to push us
around we've got breaking news now this
law has just passed the florida
legislature here to tell us about it is
the speaker of the florida house that
would be chris sproul speaker sprouse
thank you so much for coming on
michael it's great to be with you thanks
for having me this is so
incredibly encouraging finally
republicans growing a spine not just to
fight back against elected democrats but
to fight back against woke corporations
notably disney which is a kid's company
a family company it's it's supposed to
be protecting kids and giving us good
entertainment to kids not preaching
radical sexual ideologies
what does this law do
well thanks for the question i look this
law is really
its approach to to take disney and treat
them like every other company in the
state you know you and i've had the
opportunity to talk before about what
they did on the on the bill to protect
kids in school from you know radical
ideology when they're five and six years
old and then not having to learn about
transgenderism but you know and disney
of course came out and said they they
didn't support that law then people
started asking the question well why is
disney first of all why they have that
position it's super bizarre but isn't
disney granted you know special
privileges on behalf of the taxpayer and
now they're weaponizing that those
privileges as a way to mislead the
public about what the law is so the
reedy creek taxing district and there's
actually six districts that are like
this that you know they they were
created um before the 1968 florida
constitution which modified all these
things and gives them special poverty
basically they're allowed to operate
what amounts to their own government
their own city they tax themselves they
build their own roads they have their
own fire department all of this they do
themselves outside the confines of any
sort of elected representation in the
community or elected officials or
accountability from the public so so
when this happened michael and people
started raising those issues we went
back and looked at it realized there's
only six entities like this none of them
are corporations except for disney one
of them is a law library a mosquito
control district and then of course
disney who's using that opportunity as a
way to take millions of dollars and then
of course recently you know mislead the
public so you know governor desantis you
know the house and senate have now taken
upon ourselves to to correct that um
error from the 1968 constitution and to
make sure that disney is treated like
everybody else so
this special tax district that we're
talking about which basically gives
disney its own government in in the
territory that it occupies this goes
back 60 years this is a pretty big deal
if you're upending this now
i think a lot of people many liberals
and a lot of conservatives too believed
that the florida republicans would sort
of back down come to some compromise
with disney and that's not what's
happening this seems to constitute an
escalation of the fight of florida
republicans with the disney corporation
people can view that however they want i
can tell you that you know when we look
at these things when we find this and we
say to ourselves gosh why are we
allowing any corporation whether it's
disney which of course is you know
synonymous with florida or any other
corporation or company takes taxpayer
power uh escape accountability and then
weaponize that as and to use their
platform and mislead the public on items
of public policy and and we shouldn't do
that with anyone you know these special
taxing districts michael there are other
ones none of them have the ability to do
what disney can do disney could
construct their own nuclear power plant
uh under current law in the state of
florida so you know these are things
that haven't been looked at since 1968
after this incident we went back we
looked at it and we're saying look we're
not going to allow this thing without
accountability um to weaponize us
against us what i would say to you too
is is while this is you know i think
unique because it's disney the reality
is we've have a history of doing this
last year when we were doing the the
protect women's sports bill the ncaa
came out and they said well if you know
the florida legislature
passes this bill to protect women's
sports we're going to boycott sporting
events in the state of florida and i
think that that was their way of
realizing look florida you know sports
is important to us like it is in many
other states across the country but we
didn't back down not only do we pass the
bill but we passed a provision off the
house floor um that got into that law
that which which said that if you
boycott us we boycott you so no
university the university of florida
florida state there can't be members of
the ncaa if you decide to to boycott the
state of florida you know what happened
michael they didn't boycott a single
sporting event in the state of florida
so i think we've got a history here now
of punching back when these kinds of
things happen and we find that when you
do that you're all the better for it
the ncaa example is really important
because there have been other republican
governors who have been afraid of the
ncaa and when push comes to shove they
say look boys should not compete in
girls sports it's not fair it's weird
it's wrong
but you get the phone call from the
corporate donor you get the phone call
from the ncaa and when push comes to
shove they won't sign the bill they'll
back down they cave into that corporate
pressure
i i
i love what you're doing i think it's
phenomenal i i could not possibly be
more enthusiastic about it
but we should not pretend that there are
not consequences here you are opening
yourself up to huge political
liabilities it takes a lot of political
courage to do what you and your
colleagues in the florida legislature
and governor desantis are doing right
now because disney is a very powerful
corporation with lots and lots of money
that can throw its weight around are you
afraid of the political consequences
here
i'm not afraid and the reason i'm not
afraid is i'm more afraid of what
happens when we don't stand up to folks
like the ncaa or stand up to disney and
what they were doing because what do we
essentially do is we give over our state
and whatever the ncaa says or whatever
they say in california in a corporate
boardroom and a company like disney or
any other company we have to now adapt
our lives as floridians to the wishes of
you know california executives or ncaa
officials and we're just not going to do
it you know we here we represent the
people the state of florida we don't
represent these companies we are happy
when businesses come here we're happy
that businesses thrive here we're always
ranked top five in business climate
every year over year this is a great
state to do business but we're not going
to be bullied by corporate boardrooms or
by hedge funds who own large stocks in
these companies who want to dictate how
we run our state we're just not going to
do it this is a great point because i
have a lot of friends who have moved to
florida recently one of my
good friends and colleagues ben shapiro
moved to florida recently and lots of
others have as well because it's a great
business climate and because there's a
lot more political freedom there than in
other states particularly the states
that that some of us have fled like
california so what you're saying is look
we're a big strong state we've got a lot
of leverage here we've got a lot of
power we're a big act we're very
attractive and and we're we're going to
use that to make sure that we don't let
the the cart
put the cart in front of the horse and
let the tail wag the dog and let these
corporations actually take us for
granted
yeah look the reality is it's florida's
leadership style that has benefited
companies like disney remember during
the the pandemic i mean california
wouldn't let them open at all uh you
know out in california florida disney
was was open people were going back to
work families were coming here they were
spending money they were staying in
hotels you know a massive benefit to
every company to every business owner
every child in the state of florida um
but that that same freedom that comes
from you know the elected officials who
are represented by the you know who
represent the people who make those
decisions it is it is their decisions
it's the people's decision it is not the
company's decision so when they want to
take that special privilege
power and platform that they have been
given by floridians by taxpayers and
then weaponize it and mislead them i
mean let's be honest like this this law
where they came out you saw the
statements michael they totally misled
the public as to what the law did and
i'm sure they did it for a lot of
reasons that had nothing to do with the
actual law we passed but we just can't
stand idly by and be threatened by by
companies or by associations like the
ncaa and i think that florida is going
to be a better place for it if we just
spend the message hey come here do
business here but don't use your your
special power and your special privilege
uh to try to reshape florida or to bully
elected leaders this is an important
message in a way you're saying disney
help us help you help us and the
leadership that we've given you in
florida don't squander that and turn it
into every woke dystopia many of the
places that have caused you a lot of
grief so this this just happened we are
we are speaking right now just after the
bill passed the florida legislature so
what was the process for the bill and
what happens now when does this go into
effect
yeah so we'll we'll officially pass it
and vote tomorrow you know the senate
has you know passed the bill got it over
to the house we'll vote tomorrow it will
pass michael and then we'll go to the
governor's desk uh you know for his
signature and it would be you know
effective upon his signature which i
imagine will happen quickly so you know
this was a very quick process we just
announced that we were going to do it
the other day i was with the governor
and we were signing a higher education
bill which among other things made sure
that there's you know transparency and
curriculum right because the same thing
that's happening in corporations we want
to make sure that kids as they enter
higher education know what they're
getting into and know what's actually
being taught but when we were signing
that bill is when governor desantis you
know announced that we were going to do
this we've been working together and
we're going to get it done and get it to
his desk this week so we're going to see
this and i
do suspect that like so many other good
ideas that have come out of florida you
might see other states around the
country beginning to adopt similar
policies to maybe take away some of
those legal special privileges that
corporations have that they abuse at
taxpayer expense
yeah you know i hope so i you know i
hope that other leaders throughout the
throughout the state uh throughout the
country recognizing the leadership of
governor desantis and the republican-led
legislature in florida on these issues
and you know obviously it's not just
related to disney i think this is
obviously something we've seen play out
in corporate america where you know a
company who makes widgets wants to
decide that you know they want to use
whatever you know power and privileges
they have to sort of reshape you know
society in the in the image of the
corporate boardroom rather than focus on
whatever their mission is and i think
you know in the state of florida we've
always taken the approach that we want
to be very business friendly we want to
stay out of the way we want to you know
get rid of regulations so businesses and
innovators and entrepreneurs can thrive
but when you when you violate that
privilege by taking these these special
privileges which you should never have
gotten to begin with and weaponize it as
a way to mislead the public because some
california executive says it was a good
idea or the ncaa says it's a good idea
we all lose i mean we all lose as a
society when we give over what would
power which should belong to the people
to to corporate board rooms that was
never the way that this was intended
this is a newer phenomenon in the last
you know decade or so and it's got to
stop and i think the only way it's going
to stop is if leaders across the country
say look we're not going to tolerate it
you make widgets make widgets um but but
don't take your special privileges and
weaponize it and not only is disney
misleading the public but but disney is
wielding its power to undermine the will
of florida voters the majority of whom
support the parental rights and
education bill the majority of democrats
even nationally support the parental
rights and education bill it's not even
really close so so what you're having
here is not just deception from a major
media company but you're having them
wielding power power that they've
accumulated by the way with special
privileges uh in in the state uh to to
undermine the will of voters absolutely
cannot handle that last question for you
i know you're very busy
what do you expect disney and perhaps
other people who are affected by this to
do next
yeah i don't think they're gonna do
anything next you know i think that you
know they're gonna you know uh you know
go back to the drawing board i think
that they probably realized that you
know this is not something that they
should have gotten involved in um that
they shouldn't have taken this special
privilege that they had and weaponized
it um i think they they probably know
although i doubt they'll admit it that
they you know they misled and certainly
misread or misled um on what the the law
actually did so look what we've seen in
the past is you know regardless of you
know political repercussions and what
companies want to do you know against
people who voted away they didn't want
to vote that's going to happen michael
that can happen every year um you know
we haven't governed that way here in the
state of florida and i think we've been
successful because we can make our case
directly to the voters and explain why
it is we do what we do and i think to
your point earlier i think that's what
we need to see out of our leaders across
the country luckily we're blessed with
governor desantis uh you know who leads
from the front and has been very bold on
these issues so it has allowed us as a
legislature uh to really lean in and
we're going to continue to do that
absolutely right not only is it the
right thing to do and it is the right
thing to do and it takes guts to do it
but i suspect it's a political winner i
think this is what people want it's what
republicans want i i think it's what
democrats want it's it's just it's just
right all around speakers people can
find you by the way if you haven't tuned
in already check out uh speaker
sprouse's podcast red
white
and blue r-e-a-d great podcast where we
talk about books and yours truly was
actually on it not too long ago you're
very busy so uh please go out and keep
doing great stuff speaker sprouse thank
you for coming on the show
thanks michael great to be with you
appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
you